lord dieben is the chairman of the
climate change committee and he's
delivering a grim report on government
plans to get to net zero carbon
emissions by 2050.
his verdict
lots of grand promises but nowhere near
enough detail as things stand with the
current program that the government has
net zero will not happen that is true
quite a number of departments have not
yet got into their stride and what we're
saying is we haven't got any time to
wait you know this is very serious it's
no longer possible to ignore the fact
that we will make this planet
uninhabitable if we don't act now
among the major failures identified the
committee describes a shocking gap in
policy for better insulated homes
richard shears already knows this all
too well he made his house more energy
efficient without any government
guidance and now helps others to do the
same it can be confusing for people
starting on the retrofit journey because
there are so many different points of
contact and there's so many different
messages out there that
knowing where to start can be can be a
real headache agriculture and land use
are also singled out for what's
described as glacial progress we really
do want to see that incentivization we
want to see that policy
really help farmers formulate a plan but
i think we do need government to take it
seriously but it's not all bad news
the report says that great progress has
been made on electric vehicles and on
renewable energy but it will make for
very uncomfortable reading for the
government and for boris johnson who as
prime minister has consistently said
that action on climate change is a top
priority
his critics though have never been
convinced
we have a prime minister who essentially
is a climate cheat he's using all the
language to suggest that he's taking
action on climate change but as this
damning report makes so clear he
literally is not doing that there is
this big gulf between his words and his
action
in a statement a government spokesperson
said over the past three decades the uk
has driven down emissions faster than
any other g7 country and we have clear
plans to go further
we are leading the world on climate
change helping over 90 percent of
countries set net zero targets during
our cop 26 presidency up from 30 percent
two years ago
but grabbing the headlines and
delivering on the detail at home are two
very different things and the chasm
between the two must be closed if the
government is to keep its promises on
tackling climate change
hannah thomas peter sky news in
westminster